I think that the importance of
businesses social role is growing very,
very rapidly and there's only going to
continue to expand.
Um,
I think there will come a time in the
very near future within five to eight
years when almost every single major
company will simply have to pick up the
social glove and acknowledge what their
social role contribution footprint is.
They won't be able to bolt it on and
say,
hey,
we're a good company.
Or say,
Hey,
please talk to my csr,
Executive Mike,
a corporate social responsibility.
It will executive.
It will get more and more important and
more and more wired into the DNA of
organizations of why for two really
important reasons.
One,
consumers and employees are demanding
it,
particularly most notably millennials
who want to work for companies that are
making a difference and who simply won't
devote their time or invest their energy
and companies that are not,
or in companies that pretend to be an
aren't really,
um,
so and consumers are going to vote
increasingly,
particularly if we continue on this sea
of disillusionment with this massive app
disillusioned with our government in the
face of a massive advocation of
stewardship.
As consumers get more and more
disillusioned with government,
they're more and more interested to use
other avenues to vote with their dollars
or vote with their feet or make a
positive difference in a world in which
that difference is so important.
So the first reason is consumers and
employees are demanding it.
Second reason is the world.
The planet,
the collective global village can't
really survive the next 20 years and
sustain itself without the knowledge,
the resources,
the power of business and businesses.
Social problems are now business
problem.
So,
you know,
Samuel Johnson once said,
nothing so focused as a man's thoughts
like the prospect of hanging well with
the environmental system.
And the global financial system,
we have two very important ticking time
bombs and and there are many others that
flow out of that are that are there that
are part of the global,
if you will,
challenges ahead.
But we simply cannot navigate those
challenges.
We can't solve the problems.
We can't build a sustainable future for
our kids,
much less our grandkids if we don't have
a have business.
Very,
very involved literally out the social
at the village,
at the school level.
And so I think that that the social role
of business,
it,
it is an enormous issue.
But I think finally the lot of
companies,
particularly large banks right now in
the wake of the last year and a half,
and then the wake of what many of us
think of an astounding behavior on the
part of banking executives.
I think large banks are hustling to find
good bolt on for their social
citizenship and their social role.
And I also.
And so I think bolt bolt-ons add on.
Let me brush up but tarnished reputation
by throwing money at x or y.
cause I think consumers and lots of
other folks are real quick to pick that
up and to and to call a spade a spade
and see it for exactly what it is.